(upbeat music)
- I'm Elina.
- And I'm Sarah.
That was weird.
(laughing)
And I'm Sarah!
And I'm Sarah, and we are Challah Hub.
- [Elina] Today, we're going to show you
how to make a vegan challah.
Challah Hub is a Los Angeles-based delivery company.
We deliver challah every Friday.
- [Sarah] Everyone loves it, vegan or not.
- [Elina] What is challah?
A challah is braided bread traditionally eaten
on the shabbat table for Jewish people everywhere.
It's the thing that people gather around, every shabbat...
Shabbat is every Friday.
It's meant to be a time of rest and connection.
(gasping)
(laughing)
Should we just keep it?
- Just keep it.
- [Elina] Guys, baking is real.
This is real, this is what happens in life.
- [Sarah] After we had already started Challah Hub,
about six months in, maybe less than that,
I decided to go vegan.
There wasn't any vegan challah options out there,
and there's a lot of vegans out there.
And Elina amazingly was like, okay,
if we can find a delicious vegan challah recipe.
So, we tested and tested
and come up with a really amazing vegan recipe
that we're super proud of.
- [Elina] The thing that's interesting is
it's a religious bread, right?
It's associated with Judaism,
but a lot of our followers on Instagram
and a lot of our customers are not Jewish,
and they don't have to be.
If the thing at the center
of your shabbat table is our bread,
then we just think that's the coolest thing ever.
- [Sarah] Really, Elina and I's friendship
has not existed without challah.
The first time we met, it was when I was at a brunch
showing pictures of challah that I had baked,
and Elina was like, 'I'll buy you brunch
if we bake challah together.'
I was like, 'deal, I love a free brunch!'
- [Elina] I've been doing so much research
and looking up so many videos on YouTube.
I had never baked challah before I met Sarah.
For me, it was kind of like a catch up
when it comes to braiding.
- [Sarah] Yeah, the student has surpassed the teacher.
I cannot do a six-strand nearly as nice as she can.
- [Elina] Sarah has the patience
to create amazing sculptures with challah.
I have no patience for it.
- [Sarah] The joke is that I do all of that stuff,
but then Elina makes sure everything actually gets done.
- [Elina] The business stays a business.
So, there's a lot of crossover with what we both do,
but when it comes down to it,
the stuff that I really don't wanna do,
she is really happy doing
and is really good at doing and vice versa.
We're gonna make a four-strand round challah.
- [Sarah] A tic tac toe setup,
and then you're just gonna weave all the way around,
every other strand over,
and then you go back the other direction.
Yeah, and if anything looks weird,
you can just tuck it right under and no one will know.
Really that's what bread making's all about,
hiding the wonky parts.
- [Elina] We're really different.
Every time we go and do classes,
people are like 'whats the right way to do this?'
And depending on which one of us you ask,
you'll get a different answer.
- It's true.
- Mine's the right one, so...
(laughing)
- [Sarah] Next we're gonna do a rainbow six-strand challah.
For braiding, when you're laying out your strands,
each position is how you count what strand number it is.
- [Elina] If we make colored dough,
we love using all the natural dyes that are out there
like matcha, spirulina,
dragon fruit powder, blueberry powder.
There's so much out there.
- [Sarah] And don't stress if it's not perfect,
that's the other thing.
A lot of people are like,
'oh God, the braid looks so hard and crazy,'
and you know, this one is going to be difficult.
- [Elina] Sometimes when you try to connect
the different colors to each other,
you might have a difficult time,
but we promise that once you bake it it will look great.
- [Sarah] And no one's gonna complain.
You're makin' rainbow bread!
But when it comes to actually making challah at home,
it's artisan, so it can be wonky lookin'
and that's totally fine.
- We love our wonky challah.
To me, challah means family and friends,
specifically on a Friday night,
and then, for sure, french toast.
I think that's the best.
- [Sarah] Don't wrap your challah if it's hot.
No one wants that.
It's gonna get all soggy.
Take your challah out of the oven, put it on a cooling rack,
let it chill out, and then once it's cool,
then you can cut into it, rip into it.
- [Elina] We always have the fight rip or cut.
- And you cut it,
- I'm definitely...
- You cut the challah.
- No, you rip it.
- [Sarah] That's disgusting, you can't share...
You're going around and...
- What are you talking about?
- [Sarah] It's fine,
it's like animals getting into the challah.
- [Elina] I can't enjoy challah when I cut it.
- Really?
- No.
- [Sarah] I think you're lying.
- [Both] Ta da!
(groaning)
- Oh my God, it's so fluffy!
- So good.
Can I just see it for a second?
- Sure.
- Haha!
- Wait, what?
- [Andrew] Oh, yes.
(upbeat music)